dans le droit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça veut dire que d'un côté donald trump
est quelqu'un qui a été régulièrement
élu de l'autre c'est façon de procéder
ses manières de parler les décisions
imprévisible qu'il prend qui ont été
souvent soumises à aucune autorité
préalable que tout cela constitue un
personnage politique qui ressemble en
réalité aux personnages qui ont illustré
les fascismes comme par exemple du
solide
la france est assez éloignée du
qu'américain sauf absolument sur le fond
parce que comme en amérique
quelque chose de la démocratie
parlementaire est en crise en france et
maquereau en a été malgré tout le
produit puisqu'ils n'étaient inaugure
allemand le produit d'aucun des grands
partis traditionnels et il a cela de
commun avec train d'être atypique du
point de vue de l'histoire politique
française
[Musique]
je pense pas du tout que les filets
jaunes et c'était des révolutionnaires
au sens au lieu où je l'entends pour le
réseau fondamental qu'ils ont toujours
situé leur action à l'intérieur du
système politique et économique existant
non nous n'avons nullement réclamé la
fin ou la transformation radicale mais
simplement ils ont réclamé d'être pris
en considération mieux pris en
considération par l'état macro miens
ceux qui quand même fait un contraste
très vif entre l'amplitude de leur
mouvement et sa durée d'un côté et la
faiblesse de ce qu'il proposait si on
entend par communisme le paradigme
soviétique ou chinois je pense qu'il a
fait son temps il a montré les raisons
profondes de son échec
si on entend par communisme son
inspiration originel au sens de marx qui
est résumée en un certain nombre de
grands principes internationaliste
économique anti propriété des moyens de
production etc
je pense que il est plus que jamais
d'actualité
[Musique]
je les ai déjà formulé une fois mais
leur formule je formule 3 2 principaux
le premier c'est que je souhaiterais
tout en étant un peu inquiet sur ce
point que le mouvement actuel sur les
retraites soit victorieux les mouvements
ont besoin enfin d'une victoire sur des
points précis et le renoncement du
gouvernement à cette loi ou l'échec de
cette loi de façon générale serait une
véritable victoire donc je la souhaite
le deuxième je souhaite que les tensions
internationales ne finisse pas comme
elles l'ont fait au moment de la guerre
de 14 ne finisse pas pas provoqué un
incendie planétaire qui serait
probablement pour l'humanité une
catastrophe sans précédent et que rien
ne semble absolument interdire
aujourd'hui compte tenu des décisions
des différents acteurs et du caractère
insoluble d'un certain nombre de
contradictions et la troisième serait
que à travers tout cela quelles que
soient les circonstances
l'idée communiste au sens où je
l'entends de façon peut-être
expérimental et dans des lieux
particuliers soit renaissante et
expérimentés
[Musique]